a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever before as a new
subscriber joining today you'll pay just
one pound a week for unlimited online
and app access in your first year to
subscribe today go to spectator.co.uk
for a slash tv offer
[Music]
and finally has the right gone too far
in the culture wars the spectator's
associate editor douglas murray says
that perhaps it isn't wise to use the
left's tactics to explain douglas joins
me now
douglas great to see you on spectator tv
you write in your column for the
magazine this week about how the right
is retaliating against the culture wars
in the united states tell us about it
yes well as i mentioned in the piece
there's been an inevitable backlash
brewing for some years
the left has been able for years to
accuse people of racism homophobia
misogyny and much more with absolute
impunity uh
you don't have to back up the claims you
don't have to prove it people say well
if it's not true then why not sue and
the answer is how can you sue and end up
in a court of law over somebody's claim
on twitter particularly if you're just
in a private individual so this has been
going on for years we've all known it
we've all seen it
as it's as it's been brewing and i've
always said it's inevitable that at some
point people would find an accusation to
level back
and that's now arrived it's arrived in
the us in the form of the term groomer
some people may not be uh familiar with
this not everyone follows the uh online
and offline culture wars that closely
but groomer is a very interesting
accusation that the writers started to
play back
um and it's as i say in the piece it's
got some sense to it which is the only
thing that our society actually does
abhor even more than racism is
child abuse
so leveling child abuse accusations of
somebody is is a is a is a good way as
it were to hit somebody hard and low and
in the last few months in particular
segments of the american right have
realized that this is a very personal
accusation and one which they can use
back at portions of the left now how did
this come about i traced it among other
things to a strange corner of the
culture war which you know kate which
happened about a year ago which was um
around about something called drag queen
story hour and drag queen story hour was
the discovery that some school children
were being read stories in a library by
a drag queen
um it became a huge sort of culture war
issue and segments of the right
particular religious rights said this is
this is basically sodom and gomorrah
this is this is this is babylon um and
and much more but then people started to
keep an eye on among other things the
way in which pride month
and other
segments of the what's now become
lgbtqia
plus agenda um started to move into the
mainstream so for instance parents
bringing their children to pride events
which in my view in many cases is
totally inappropriate
starting to see children at events they
shouldn't be at
uh the right started to say things like
aha
you this is a groomer event
it happened with for instance some
teaching in schools about
gender fluidity about a hundred genders
and all this sort of thing stonewall the
british
charity which i think is a lamentable
organization now uh uh just last week
put out a tweet saying that
two-year-olds should know their gender
identity and also and and basically
segments of the writers realize not just
that there is something crazy about
assuming that even a two-year-old can
say you know i'm gender non-conforming
or i'm a lesbian or i'm gay or i'm trans
or anything else what do you know a two
for god's sake uh um not just that this
is crazy to be teaching children this
but that a shortcut to stopping it is to
level this accusation
groomer
douglas the way that you talk about okay
groomer in the piece suggests that
you're not terribly impressed with the
use of the term um as you just pointed
out there there might be examples that
understandably deeply frustrate or worry
sensible people but that the accusation
itself is just making the culture wars
worse and it's taking us to a place in
our conversations where we cannot have
any kind of conversation back and forth
that doesn't result in the nastiest most
ugly accusations going back and forth
that's right i i do actually fear that i
i think that i think one of the
questions which i've written about in
the magazine in the past of recent years
has been how do you respond to an
accusation um
which is not disprovable and the
accusation of racism is not disprovable
i mean a person can't get it off them if
it's if they're accused of it uh they
can say well you know i'm i've got black
friends or i i'm not racist or i'm
married to a
black woman or whatever whatever they
say they still can't get it off them
even people who are black can't get the
accusation of racism off them and this
is this is very um
it causes an enormous amount of anger
and frustration to people i think that
groomer is a sort of accusation back at
a similar level and i do worry about the
results of it i worry about the results
of it not least because you can see a
situation where two political sides both
throw the nastiest dirtiest accusations
against each other and you sort of can't
get them off the second reason i worry
about it is that i do think there's
going to be a and i mention this in the
piece
the the the
portions of um you know the sort of
what's called the lgbtqia plus world are
going to get caught up in this they just
already are and a lot of gay people who
don't want anything to do with the
gender nonsense don't want anything to
do with you know uh drag queen strippers
and children being present don't want
anything to do with any of this are
going to get caught up in it
so that's the second reason but a third
reason is just really about a commitment
to truth which is that you always have
that option i actually wrote about this
last week in the magazine you always
have that option don't you in any
political discussion of
um will i or will i not abandon my
commitment to truth
um will i just grab the nearest thing
the nearest stick and just beat my
opponent with it or will i actually
resist that urge
and as i've written in the magazine
before in american politics today a very
distinct urge is not just to defeat your
opponent but to hurt them
to really hurt them that's one of the
one of the things about the donald trump
phenomenon is seizing donald trump as a
weapon to hurt your opponents
the democrats do that the other way
around as well so all sides are guilty
of it there's always this moment of
should i do that or try to do that and i
am as you say kate i am concerned about
it because i do think that although
there are occasions where you can say
actually you know this is deeply
inappropriate for children for instance
there are some teachers that have been
captured on things like libs of tick
tock saying things that they teach their
class that are completely inappropriate
which actually could fall into the into
the category of being groomer-like
behavior so i'm not saying that this
doesn't exist at all i think that it's a
specific accusation like the accusation
of racism that should be reserved for
specific um justifiable occasions
what i worry about
is a decision by as i say people who
want to win a culture you want to say
actually we're going to give up on that
we're just going to level it as hard and
often as we can and that'll show them
and douglas another point you
quite thoughtfully make i think in your
pieces is that this seems to be a blown
up from a storm in the teacup that drag
queen story hour was not happening in
every school across the united states um
and actually as you point out in the
magazine you know there's something
quite lovely and nice in many
circumstances about drag queens and
their performances and
pen to mind absolutely well sure i mean
that's that's that's one very
family-friendly example um but that you
know if we wrap this all up together
we're actually in danger of taking what
again most nice sensible people can
judge for themselves as appropriate or
not appropriate for children and we're
just putting disgusting labels on it and
and that's wrong too i mean that's the
antithesis of being progressive and and
you know i think on the right and the
left you can be progressive um you know
you you can you can be open-minded and
we're basically just trying to lump it
all in together and shut it all down for
the sake as you say beating the other
side up yeah well i'm not particularly
interested in being progressive myself
fair enough to each their own um but but
you know i
the general point here just being that
you know we've come a long way as a
society when it comes to accepting other
people's sexual orientations and being
open-minded to adults doing you know
what it is that they want to do as long
as you're not harming anybody else and
we are in danger of taking what is
objectively bad behavior but often very
specific and and very narrow and just
trying to put labels on everything that
it doesn't need a label we don't need to
get involved
well
yeah what i'd say is that what's
actually going on is it's classic
in-group out-group behavior
and our group discovers an in-group
behavior and and worries about it
there's a combination of that which as i
say the internet is particularly good
and useful for as a tool
and the second thing is uh the undoubted
example of that that does exist
particularly in america of children
being uh subjected to things that they
just shouldn't be subjected to they
shouldn't be made aware of they're far
too young it's it's it's ridiculous
there's always a worry about children
and such
than the sexualization of children it's
a completely legitimate and
understandable fear so fear all parents
have it's a it's a fear that society
should have are we sexualizing children
too young that's an absolutely
legitimate fear of the society and so
when things blow up around children it's
completely understandable
and there should be a debate about what
is taught in school there should be a
debate about inappropriate things shown
to children and every parent knows this
and every school should know this and
school should be responsive to parent
fears uh but i do think that there is a
um a specific a specific corner of this
which is um potentially highly
inflammatory and if i can just say so
quickly
one example of how inflammatory it is is
that twitter which is effectively as
much as we might resist it the de facto
town square twitter has banned the use
of the word groomer on the platform now
and that's very interesting because this
speaks also to this pent-up anger that
is that is brewing on elements of the
right twitter has not banned the use of
the left's favorite cudgels it has not
said you know
any labor mp who accuses boris johnson
of racism is going to have their tweet
taken down it doesn't say that no no no
still allows the
false accusations it could be leveled by
the left primarily by the left to be
allowed whilst trying to silence the
false accusations mainly false
accusations made by people on the right
that's that's an example of the
exacerbation of a problem that i think
we're going to see more of um i'd like
to think that through very delicate
issues like this issues of sexuality
particularly issues around children i'd
like to think that our societies could
have these arguments out sensibly uh
reasonably and with due concern
for the health and well-being of
children i would i would think that the
least likely way to have that debate is
to accuse any and all opponents of being
child abusers uh but that's where we are
and if you want to as i say in the piece
if you want to see a little glimpse into
the 2020s political debate you can see
an unending war where two sides both
level knowingly false accusations
against the other
you know douglas i i really despair
because i feel like if the right and the
republican party institutionally goes
down this road of trying to match the
left you know punch for punch on the
culture war it's going to undermine
other fundamental values it has i
remember ron desantis not so long ago in
response to drag queen hour talking
about how he was considering getting
social services involved if there were
any evidence that a parent were to
introduce their child to a drag queen or
take their kid to a drag queen show now
you and i might have opinions of
everybody will have opinions about what
is appropriate at certain ages and we
should be able to have that discussion
but i was quite shocked to see a
republican governor
talking about taking one's child away
from them i mean we are talking about
like the most core fundamental frankly
american values about
family and your children and that
parents come first not the state
and
you know we have to be able to have
these conversations without trying to
use the tools of the state
to attack our opponents and
personally i think this is a an element
of the trump era that has come to
dominate the republican party that
actually you play as dirty as your
opponent and you use the tools at your
disposal um you know and i lament it i'd
be interested on your thoughts on this
yeah i think that's an interesting point
i mean i think desantis was specifically
referring to i mean some videos that
emerged of
uh children being taken like strip shows
basically where uh they're being
encouraged to put money into the pants
of uh a a drag queen stripper
and and that's that's the sort of thing
that quite understandably enrages a lot
of people people saying like what are
they doing there why would the parents
be taking them to this and again i'm
sorry to return to it but again
the
whole gay uh world is going to get
caught up in this if
no kind of boundaries whatsoever are
exercised um
but so desantis i if i remember rightly
was responding to
videos like that but you're right kate
that i mean a normal conservative
response would have been look
uh um
we will advise parents not to to be so
irresponsible as to take children such a
thing we will of course
expect that schools wouldn't knowingly
put children through any such thing
um but but no i mean you wouldn't you
wouldn't intervene at the level of
social services but you're right kate
this is a discovery of parts of the
american right recently which is that
they can use the tools back at their
opponents their opponents are basically
used against them and that includes you
know using the tools of the state and
much more um this is going to get very
ugly and uh as i say i mean uh a very
delicate
uh social issues need to be dealt with
you know basically very fine-tuning um
parents have to be um have to be
encouraged to good behavior they
shouldn't be brow beaten into they
certainly shouldn't be threatened by the
state into it um and everyone is gonna
have to kind of cool it a bit i think
but um why would you call it if you've
just discovered a cudgel
so incredibly effective why would you
cool it when you're standing over your
opponent uh with a cudgel that you've
long wished to wield
douglas my last question to you is
actually about the start of your piece
for the magazine this week to talk about
the culture war a bit more generally you
start by writing about a billboard in
southwark in london which has written on
it hey straight white men past the power
now southwark is one of the most
deprived local authorities in the
country and the question that
immediately pops into my head is what is
being achieved with that poster
can the left not see the extent to which
that alienates people and
you know to expand this can the right
and the left not at this point see the
extent to which just
normal people who perhaps aren't even
that political look at these crazy
accusations on both sides and think to
themselves i want nothing to do with
that they're they're not going to open
their mind they're not going to learn
any lessons from these accusations
no this billboard in southwark is is a
pure provocation
um it's by a black artist from marseille
um uh it's it's obviously approved by uh
the local authorities you can't put up
uh posters and and public works
billboards and things without going
through approval processes
as i say i think that if a billboard
said hey black guys give us your rights
or oy gays hand over the cash oh i would
like that no one would like it everybody
would condemn it everyone would say it
was racist and so far as i can see apart
from me nobody has uh noticed this or
bothered about a sign
in a in the public square
that just insults straight white men and
accuses them of being powerful and
as you say kate i mean you know
imagine imagine being a an ordinary
straight white male in southwark and
being told on top of everything else on
top of all the others sufferings
deprivations
unknown
tragedies you've gone through in your
life you're powerful you've got power
and you've got to hand it over
at at a point of a kind of threat
um
what what is achieved by this only one
thing which is a digging in of a feeling
of resentment uh and you know the mayor
of london southwark council everyone
else who approves this kind of behavior
this kind of provocation should really
be asked to rethink this uh why does it
make sense to keep insulting majority
populations most people in britain are
white
most people are heterosexual
half the population is male
why the hell would you do this other
than to just hurt people
and i'm afraid the answer is there's no
other reason it's just that
[Music]
you